[Music]
they used more men in their assault on
my home than they used to take down bin
Laden or El Chapo or Pablo Escobar I
don't think you know my god might not go
to the Christmas and all these things
that we all take for granted all of a
sudden wasn't a given anymore you are
deluded it's not happening it's not
happening I mean with respect to two
daughters it takes two to tango it is
cold my teeth are cold I don't think
I've ever felt this cold before in my
life I was a rescued child if you like
and the personal level is I can only
thank written that we were able to come
here and I was taken in by an English
family the gentlemen happened to be the
Secretary of the Labour Party in
national underline and I have with me
the label that and I wore around my neck
when I was getting on the train with my
three and a half year old sister I have
with me for people who don't believe
this has ever happened my autograph book
that my grandfather gave me the night we
were leaving and I have with me a
brochure which we will see a memorial to
the parents who were brave enough to put
us on those trains the memorial which
stands in Prague which has little
children's hands on one side of the last
window and the parents on the other
saying goodbye probably knowing that
there was they would never see us again
5% is a significant figure saying either
this this hasn't happened or it is all
just exaggerated I mean you can just
dismiss that out of hand can't you you
can't but the interesting thing is
because I talk to a lot of schools
taught her children to W eyes to
rotaries all of them never ever have
said we didn't really happen
because I have the facts to show them
that it did I wish you could see the
hundreds of letters that I get after my
talks and these are very often from
because I talk to 11 and 12 year olds
and I have one that I take with me which
I read because this child is saying
having heard my story and she finishes
off with I now cherish my parents
because I have parents to cherish that
was and that's the last end and that's
an 11 year old child who's written that
and I had those letters at home and
obviously it's certainly getting through
to the to the children like thousands of
women in the UK Laura flatty's life has
been touched by cancer she's one of the
lucky ones a smear test picked up a
cervical cancer early enough for surgery
to be able to save her life the Laura
will never forget the day she got her
diagnosis it was a million card on the
desk and the consultant it's you know
it's that old cliche of I'm so sorry
but it's cancer and excuse me I broke
there's there's no other way to put it
you know I just broke and they just let
it happen you know I think you know they
were so good they just knew I needed
that that moments are just break down
and it's so surprised and what can run
through your mind in 30 seconds in 30
seconds I'd died my children had you
know I kept saying to him you know I've
got two young children they're not going
to remember me they won't remember me if
you know if I die from this I'm gonna be
you know a picture in the house and this
area that was my mom but I don't I don't
remember her and I begged him to save me
I said you know whatever it is you need
to do you know how do we fix it it needs
to be fixed and we need to fix it now so
he said we're gonna have to wait for a
scan see where the cancer is and then
we'll go plan of action and so I had to
wait the weekend and which was my little
boy's birthday and I just remember being
at his birthday think you know you know
is this the last one I'm gonna say I've
I made it good enough I made it
memorable in affari and then I really
think you know my God might not get
another Christmas and all these things
that we all take for granted all of a
sudden wasn't a given anymore and her I
just it was a very long week and it was
such a long weekend and I just remember
thinking I've had made my life the best
it could possibly be and you know the
answer was probably no then you know I
do live a completely different life now
and so when he came I had my MRI scan
and two days later we had a plan in
action and it hadn't spread I could have
surgery and everything would be good I
didn't have to have a hysterectomy but I
was incredibly lucky I had two children
at one of each and no it's not nice
having the option taken away but do I
want more children I do I want to live
it's you know that the answer is clear
there it was my best friend's wedding
coming up and I was meant to be
bridesmaid and I just had that in mind
outside and me I want to walk down the
aisle with her and it was so touch and
go but I got my old clear and then two
days like it was the wedding so I mean I
was ghost up to the eyeballs and
painkillers kind of rattling my way down
the aisle with her but I was there which
was what I wanted and the rest as they
say is history
Roger stone is one of Donald Trump's
closest friends and most loyal allies
he appeared in court this week and
pleaded not guilty to seven criminal
charges including witness tampering and
obstruction of justice before the
hearing I asked him about the Russia
investigation and whether or not he's
willing to cooperate with Special
Counsel Robert mother well I'm willing
to tell the truth but I'm not willing to
make up stories or bear false witness
against anybody including the president
the president has done nothing wrong he
certainly hasn't colluded with Russia
and therefore I'm not going to make up
false tales about him to get to ease the
pressure on myself
that would be perjury are you willing to
talk about the conversations you had
with Donald Trump to the extent that I
can remember them but they are generally
speaking just political gossip how am i
doing in Ohio how do you what do you
think about Florida do you think we can
really win Michigan have you seen any
polling the Trump campaign done like
most modern campaigns didn't spend a lot
of money on polling and in all that time
despite the fact that the president was
tweeting about WikiLeaks with tweeting
about Russia you never once discussed
Russia that is correct and there is no
evidence to the contrary because it just
didn't happen the president answered
this question in his written
interrogatories to mr. Muller I have
answered the question before the House
Intelligence Committee those answers are
both consistent and true they leak like
a sieve or they conduct raids on your
home to depict you like a criminal like
a drug kingpin when you have no prior
criminal record and you're not accused
of any violent crime but I shouldn't be
allowed to go on you know the sky news
and and defend myself so I do have a
concern about that the idea that they
had to you know run a bin Laden like
assault although they used more men in
their assault on my home than they used
to take down bin Laden or El Chapo or
Pablo Escobar try to make me look like
public enemy number one this is an
attempt to poison the jury pool to make
me look like a criminal
they say they believed you would tamper
with evidence
I've been under investigation for two
years if I were going to tamper with
evidence which I haven't why would I
wait until last Thursday it's illogical
you measures to be put in place to try
to tackle the spiraling problem of knife
crime our home editor Jason Farrell
spoke to one gang in London if somebody
touches me here the whole my whole gang
will come to your home phones game kill
Oliver if he touched me I'm touching
your family yeah if he touched my
bedroom if you touch him him him mom
coming off key we didn't choose this
life right I'm not going to speak about
walking to meatball I need get on one
case for hard to get keys if I get in
gear I would go in like a couple of days
what do you mean you would have died in
a couple of days can you just elaborate
a little bit just for the money
where'd you get the money from over
there clients what some of you don't
even know yourself but your mates told
you I wonder if you were able to kind of
sit down with the Prime Minister for a
few minutes and say I want to explain to
you why I am involved in this life what
would you say autoimmune for urban
entities like this life change me if
take a comment from saw opportunity or
push TV so be got nothing to do
ah totally the made to put some money in
today it's a country in turmoil
protesters on the street a president
reviled by many
international support but his rival is
growing
venezuela's himself declared interim
president Ron Guido is in hiding fearing
for his life I went to speak to the man
who wants to bring change to this
country
protester taken place often end
violently more are due do you expect
them to be violent as well in Mendota
interactive world has seen this that we
are doing this peacefully why are they
doing this because they want to instill
fear in the people but what we have here
in Venezuela is hope and despite those
risks we are going to keep ourselves on
the streets we will continue to get
support from the world not only Europe
for example the ultimatum given to
Maduro who says he believes that Maduro
would do anything to keep in power
indoors in Dora there's no doubt about
it that's almost a guarantee from a
regime with so many social and political
and economic demands when they don't
have ways to solve these problems they
use violence they've killed 40 young
people and that hurts a lot 700 people
detained but that will not stop the
social and political pressure and we can
enforce the majority we have as a
parliament and as the president in
charge of Venezuela you are obviously in
a lot of danger this is a regime that
has a history of dealing with people
often violently or at least in prison
how do you feel about that and and and
and you fear for your family as well no
- aha I mean there have been threats on
my life and they're not recent my
generation in Venezuela grew up in
dictatorship and we've had to deal with
losing friends to protest see them
imprisoned or see them being tortured
that's the reality what we fear is this
carries on the eyes to the right 317 the
nose to the left 300
Fraser may had some success in the
Commons on brexit this week but the
country remains prettily divided and so
does a party we saw evidence of that on
all our politics before Tuesday's key
votes when the Tory backbencher and a
Seabury clashed with the brexit minister
Lord Kalinin I just said that these were
all devices to delay r exit that's
exactly what this government is now
seeking to do because you're now your
government my government's policy is to
go back to the European Union and to
renegotiate the withdrawal agreement I'm
the backstop even though we were told it
was the only deal in town and the year
you've made it very clear they will not
shift on the backstop so because the
point of going back on Europe is the
Prime Minister's because we lost the
vote in the House of Commons by 230
votes many of your colleagues could not
accept it this is what you say we should
be doing which is listening to the will
of the House of Commons of course we
thought it was a good deal that was the
deal we thought deserve support it
didn't get that support what is known by
a huge majority of Commons and we are
going to go back to the European Union
and seek to renegotiate and in a way
that is except basis so what basis will
you seek to renegotiate the Northern
Trust on the basis of having to do what
is the US we are we are going to ask
them to look at the various concerns
that have been expressed and I won't be
too specific about it but for any
foreign for instance the fact that it
would be indefinite some possibly of a
clause to look at it again to re-examine
it to give the House of Commons further
options that have it a time limit there
are a number of different multiple
options that could be put in there that
could make it acceptable to the House of
Commons because if it isn't acceptable
and we don't have a deal and we end up
with a No Deal scenario that was a good
idea if we hadn't done all these things
at the beginning of the process as
opposed to the process what the plan is
that can do now thanks to the
parliamentary decision for which I must
say I and many others have campaigned
what she can do now is go to Brussels
get the freedom clause because the UK
needs just as she rides off on her
unicorn
to Brussels the reality chat London in
my phone this is from mr. stuff
spokesperson the back stop is part of
the withdrawal agreement and the
withdrawal agreement is not open for
renegotiation the December European
Council conclusions are very clear on
this point you are deluded it's not
happening it's not happening I mean with
respect to two daughters it takes two to
tango there is a negotiation going on
you would expect him to say that but
believe me the EU has every incentive to
give us the deal we nee this weather
event is called a polar vortex which has
when very cold air rushes south from the
Arctic this one's particularly dramatic
and widespread which means that tens of
millions of people across the country
are facing this plunge in temperatures
it's so cold that your eyelashes are
frozen chilly do you live here I do yeah
you ever experience cold like it it's
pretty cold tell me how you stay warm in
conditions like this I mean just like
Lehr and good except good like long
johns and good layers and stuff you're
fine back inside soon yeah yeah I walked
out to the planetarium going to see the
lake I want to see the river so see I
don't know you don't have that many
opportunities to really experience this
kind of fun what's it like being outside
at least my dear
lordy Lordy it is cold my teeth are cold
actually so it's cold that's quite an
achievement
I know teeth being cold I agree have you
I felt cold like this before never not
my life no cold within are an article
right : anyway what do you think about
how's it feeling your skin it hurts it's
cold
you don't precise somewhere warm now
yeah we came out just to take a picture
there and now we're going back in it is
cold my lips are frozen and I've only
been out here about two minutes you're
shivering yes I am I'm from Atlanta
Georgia we didn't get this cold I don't
think I've ever felt this cold before in
my life
and we've only been out here for a few
minutes like you said so worried about
frostbite now I'm starting to yeah what
does it feel like to be out in this
temperature invigorating that's it
that's it what what effect does the cold
had on you well all my appointments have
been cancelled so I'm heading back to
North Carolina where it's a bit warmer a
bit warmer
a Sky News team will soon head to the
depths of the ocean will broadcast a
live TV news bulletin from under the sea
and will see firsthand the damage
plastic pollution is doing to marine
life there I spoke to the UN Special
Envoy for the oceans Peter Thompson
there's no doubt that the ocean is in
deep trouble and of course your viewers
would be well aware of the the plastic
scourge but there are things like
overfishing of the the ocean to worry
about where we're driving our fish
stocks to extinction
there is the climate change effects of
ocean warming and ocean acidification
deoxygenation spreading of dead zones
it's not a great story as we enter the
Anthropocene age but we have a plan to
save the health of the ocean and I
really commend sky for what it's doing
in this regard and Peter you talked
about the threats there overfishing
pollution plastics you mentioned sea
warming what do you consider what does
the UN consider to be the biggest threat
to the ocean at the moment without doubt
climate change
therefore fidelity to the Paris climate
agreement and the implementation scaling
up of our ambition you'd be aware that
the secretary-general United Nations has
called for a high-level climate summit
in September in New York this year this
is the key to it because it's the GHG
emissions in the atmosphere which are
causing the ocean warming and
acidification and sea level rise and 80%
of our ocean problems
yeah and how difficult with that in mind
is it when countries like the United
States and others are not showing a real
commitment I find that the United States
if you look at the people with
philanthropies the states of the cities
and so on are all very committed so I'm
not too worried about that but you know
it's for all of us individuals cities
governments multilateral organizations
nobody can step aside from the
responsibility of meeting the Paris
climate change goals and heightening
them because they the frightening thing
is that we're still on track for
three to four degree world when we've
just had this special report come out
from the IPCC which says that anything
over 1.5 once we get up to two degrees
you know we've lost coral reefs for
example and that's where we're heading
at the moment so a time for action from
everybody
[Music]
[Music]
we're live on Sky News here we're just
admiring your air your snowman and
there's a snow dog here as well you
spotted him thank you not finished yet
work in progress so how much snow have
you got around your awai well we're from
Wellington yeah we intend and using all
of Warrington snow to finish this it's
it's just so beautiful brilliant it's
fantastic so we're really hoping for a
snow day today and there we got it so
the children off school and everyone
just helping you make this wonderful
song I think I'm taking more seriously
than they are
[Music]
that's a good effort really
[Music]